eecs and statistics at berkeley and one
of the
leaders of the reinforcement learning
theme
martin
hi everyone uh can you hear me yeah
um so let's open our slides
all right so it's my pleasure to uh give
an overview of the theme on
reinforcement learning for fodzy um
together with deborah shaw
at mit um i'm a co-leader of this effort
and
we've got a range of people both from
the east coast and
we we're not seeing your slides
okay um let's backtrack
hmm
can you see them now we can yep perfect
okay so um sorry about that glitch
um so we've got a range of people both
on the east coast and the west coast
um so i think it's quite exciting
actually
um i've really enjoyed in getting ready
for this talk i've spent a bit of time
reading
other people's work it's it's actually
nice to have an excuse to
uh to read in a bit more depth the work
of your colleagues
so what i'd like to do in this talk is
just give an overview along with some
highlights of particular thrusts of work
of different members of the team and
also looking ahead
to problems that are interesting
problems that we hope to work on
as part of the fodzy effort
so very broadly just a bird's eye view
of reinforcement learning
it's a very intellectually rich area
i've actually been interested in it for
many years just because it combines so
many different pieces
it has dynamics you have a stochastic
dynamical system with the notion of
state
something evolving over time it has a
notion
of a reward or a cost function to
minimize or reward function to maximize
so brings in decision-making
into the loop and the reinforcement part
really closes the loop between learning
and action
that this is the case where you
typically don't know the model
and you observe data in some form so you
need both to estimate the model to learn
but the model is just is not the end
point in itself the end point of course
is learning good policies
that allow you to behave in interesting
ways
so we have a picture here of david
blackwell
a former colleague here at berkeley of
course did a lot of seminal work
in the original formulations of um
mdps markup decision processes and so on
just high level again let me also say
that some ways it's appropriate that rl
is last because it actually has
very deep connections to a lot of the
other fodsy themes that we heard about
today
and i'll try and touch on these as we go
through certainly to causal inference
computational complexity the economics
learning thrust as well
so i think there can be some fruitful
interactions with these other themes
um in addition to being sort of
mathematically very interesting
rl is also fascinating particularly
these days because there's a very wide
range of
applications ranging from things like
digital health
robotics industrial control we've all
heard about competitive game playing
like chess and go and so on
but also things like financial and
economic systems transportation networks
in all of these areas
models from reinforcement learning are
proving useful and interesting to study
so let me just highlight um one
particular application of rl
in which one of our team members susan
murphy has been doing a lot of very nice
work over over the past five to ten
years
and that's actually making reinforcement
learning methods work for
uh personal health um so here
is a figure from one of her papers in
which they're describing the
rl model that they've set up
to be loaded onto your cell phone in
order to influence your behavior
it's trying to make you exercise more in
particular to take more steps
but it's useful to understand because it
has all the the nice ingredients
of a reinforcement learning problem um
you have a notion of time
instance at which you collect
information and make decisions so
here at the top she's showing morning
commute lunch time mid afternoon and so
on
each day there's five time instances and
in the study there
are many days you have a notion of state
because unlike in the pure bandit
setting which we'll talk about later
their
memory is important in these problems so
things like how many steps did you take
in the past
um that matters your current location
matter how often you're using your phone
matters there's a whole list of
observables here that form the state
in this model and the decision here is
actually quite simple it's just a binary
action
do they instruct the phone to give you
an activity message
or they instruct the phone to do nothing
so states actions and then rewards
rewards here are basically measured by
how many steps you take in a half hour
window after
each message was sent so obviously the
algorithm is trying to maximize
the number of steps
so this is quite interesting and already
quite challenging
in their paper they talk about a number
of the issues that i'll
bring up later on for instance
non-stationarity in this model
there's computational issues already due
to um continuous states and so on
okay so let me talk a little bit um
again just to wrap up the high level
part
um the general thrust of of this theme
is is to try and close a gap
that i think it's fair to say exists in
the current state of
rl um what we're seeing is you know
pretty tremendous empirical successes
but our current theory is kind of
lagging it's not really explaining
what's going on in practice um
and it's important to close this gap
not just because we're theorists and we
think that's interesting
but because in practice because of
issues like safety and so on
safety and stability of rl systems that
would be rolled out
uh in the real world for instance
imagine a self-driving car where people
are trying to make
reinforcement learning work if you don't
have a good understanding of its failure
modes
of its stability of policies and so on
um this is not going to work this is
going to
um cause deaths so somehow bridging this
gap
between practice and theory is is quite
important
um so broadly the theme has thrusts of
bridging this gap getting rigorous
results on the rl methods that are used
in practice
but at the same time also using
theoretical insights to
die the development of new procedures
and connecting with some of the other
thrusts in fodzy i think
trying to understand various fundamental
trade-offs that exist in
reinforcement learning for instance
between sample complexity
that just means how many samples do i
need to learn let's say a
epsilon good policy versus other
resources that we might have for
instance computational constraints
storage constraints or if we're studying
for instance multi-agent rl we might
have
communication constraints linking to
communication complexity that
that ronit was just talking about
okay so with that overview in place let
me um in the remainder of the talk i'm
going to
pick a few directions and try and sketch
out high level
what are some challenges and also give
some highlights of of work that
our team has been doing and intends to
do
to address these challenges
so one issue here is that um
in many cases if you look at how
standard algorithms scale
when applied to an unstructured
reinforcement learning
problem it's often prohibitive it can be
prohibitive in terms of
sample complexity how much data you need
to learn
and it can be prohibitive for instance
in terms of how it scales with the
dimension of the problem
how it scales with the horizon of the
problem if you have a decision problem
over some number of steps
or equivalently how it scales with the
discount factor
if you look at a discounted markov
decision process
so an important direction here is to
propose models that have structure
structure that's relevant in
applications and also methods that
exploit that structure
and to prove things about these methods
so a few lines of work here i'm just
again citing work by people that are a
member of our team
just to be clear many people are
thinking about these problems
and so this is just specific to to our
team
there's many kinds of structure that
arise in applications i'll i'll talk
about the lqr problem in a moment
let me just mention briefly factored
markup decision processes these are
decision processes in which the state
or decision variables somehow split into
groups
so very much connected to graphical
models
and uh where would factored mdps arise
um well an example from one of
suvretzra's paper would be
if you have a robot let's say a
vacuuming robot that's making decisions
about whether to clean or not
its decision about whether to clean a
corner of the living room
has nothing to do with the state of the
kitchen table
right so you could imagine having a
state that includes all parts of the
house
but decisions and and states would only
interact in in local ways
and that's exactly the idea of a
factored mdp
um for problems where you have
continuous states
things become even more challenging just
because of the usual curse of
dimensionality
and here you need structure like either
some kind of smoothness
you want your value function or your q
function to depend in a smooth way on
your states and actions
or you need things like sparsity low
rank structure and so on
so here let me just highlight quickly
some work that deborah
shaw and some of his collaborators have
been doing
on the classical q learning algorithm
one of the oldest algorithms in
reinforcement learning it's
designed to try and learn the optimal
function that tells you the
reward that you expect moving forward
from a given state action pair
so they're studying a problem that has a
continuous state and action space
and what they propose is by looking at
it in
a certain discretized form they end up
with a very large dimensional matrix
and by exploring the space by trying out
actions and
from a given state trying out actions
you sort of partially populate the
entries of this matrix
so it becomes what's known as a missing
data problem or a
matrix estimation problem with partially
observed data
they actually propose a new algorithm
for this that would actually fill in the
missing entries of the q function
they can then interpolate and then
this loop starts again so the key sort
of ingredient
here that they observe is that in
practice
in many cases q functions when you
discretize them like this to form
matrices will have
not exactly a low rank structure but a
near low rank structure
and when you have that kind of low
dimensional structure you can exploit it
with an algorithm
and they propose a particular algorithm
that does exploit it
what we're seeing here is the
performance of their algorithm in terms
of
l infinity loss on the q function
versus the iteration number and
the line above is sort of a naive method
you can see it's very poor it's
converging it's going to be consistent
but it's extremely slow
whereas these algorithms down here are
exploiting the structure so you can see
fairly dramatic speed ups by
exploiting structure now to be clear
there's still plenty of open questions
here
you can see actually the nuclear norm
method seems to behave better
but nothing is known about it they they
can't prove anything about it yet
and it's also much more computationally
expensive so
there's various open questions um that
arise
from this particular approach with low
rank structure
another vignette sort of structure or
non-structure is the distinction between
model-free versus model based methods
at a high level model-based algorithms
in some way try and estimate the
dynamics of the underlying
markov chain whereas model-free
algorithms
are more direct they go directly after
what you care about either the q
function or the policy or the value
function
and you can say well which is better and
of course
the answer really is it depends but
trying to understand
on what it depends and what are the
trade-offs between these classes
is is quite interesting
um so here let me talk briefly about
another simple model the linear
quadratic regulator
um it's sort of the simplest instance of
a continuous state and action
reinforcement learning problem you have
a linear state space
model with a quadratic reward function
so a here is the matrix that determines
the dynamics
of the markov chain
here we'll just focus on the problem of
evaluating
the reward of a fixed policy so the
policy would also
shape the form of this a
when you have a quadratic reward
function it's well known that the value
function is a quadratic function of the
state variable
so in this setting you can have two very
different approaches
the model based approach says well let's
observe transitions
x t x t plus one and so on and let's
directly estimate the dynamics matrix
and then we can plug it into a lyapunov
equation to try and estimate the value
function
okay so that's model based because it's
very tied to the linear dynamics of the
problem
whereas a model-free approach is in some
sense
less tied to dynamics the only thing it
exploits is that the value function is
quadratic
so if you have a quadratic value
function
you can do not exactly regression it's a
form of instrumental variables
um in the lifted quadratic space by
looking at the functions
of all the x's and then all the pairs of
the x's
that's a linear function a quadratic
function becomes linear after this
lifting
um what two and rex showed actually is
that if you look at the model based
approach that's shown here in blue
and you compare it to the um model free
approach
lstd or lspi that's shown here in orange
um in this case lstd is is much more
efficient
um this was the figure i think that sort
of the empirical result that motivated
their later theory
and what they ended up showing is that
the model free method
actually requires has a sample
complexity it requires
a dimension d more samples than the
direct method the model
based method okay so
what it's telling you is that if you
really believe that you have a linear
state space model
it's much better to directly estimate
the dynamics
and then learn the value function from
the learn dynamics
but of course if you don't have complete
faith in a linear state space model
then you might suspect that the model 3
approach is far more robust
you can certainly construct many mdps
that have quadratic value functions but
do not have linear dynamics
so the model free approach would still
work just fine in those cases it's
somehow much more robust to model the
specification in the dynamics
whereas the plug-in model-based approach
would fail
but understanding these kinds of
trade-offs is is quite interesting
okay so a second direction that the team
is very interested in
has to do with the classic exploration
exploitation dilemma
um this is a dilemma that we're all
familiar with for instance
when you're exploring the new city
trying restaurants or
in my case trying cafes for good coffee
once you've found a good co good cafe do
you just sort of
hunker down there and stay there forever
drinking their coffee
what if there's a better espresso
somewhere else in the city maybe you
should explore a little bit more
right so this is the classical trade-off
that um any kind of reinforcement
learning algorithm
encounters and um
these kinds of trade-offs are now i
would say relatively well understood in
the classical bandit setting just a
classical multi-armed bandit
but there's a lot of open questions that
arise in more complex settings
um a basic tool here that we heard about
earlier today for instance i think mike
mentioned it in his talk
is um the notion of ucb upper confidence
bounds
and these basically just provide you a
way of quantifying how
uncertain are you about your current
estimate of the rewards
in my example earlier how uncertain am i
about my current estimate of the quality
of this cafe's espresso
okay so at every round what these
algorithms are doing are maintaining a
combination
of an empirical estimate of the reward
along with a confidence bound that
reflects the fact that
this is an empirical estimate it's based
on only a total of
t of a samples t of a is the number of
times that you performed a particular
action
a in a total of t rounds
so i should sort of hedge my bets maybe
i just have a bad
estimate of this coffee because i
haven't
consumed enough cups of it if coffee
making or coffee drinking were somehow a
noisy observation process
okay so this idea has proven uh very
powerful
and as i said quite well understood in
the the standard bandit setting
there's been some thrusts of work uh by
different team members
um here's a snippet of work from mike
jordan and some of his collaborators
in which they take the q learning
algorithm i mentioned this algorithm
earlier
and they studied in the context where
you're actually exploring actively
you're sort of choosing
actions and exploring the space
and they essentially propose to include
a
ucb bonus an extra bonus
in the classical q function update
and they study different forms of this
hufting bonuses bernstein bonuses and so
on
and they prove a number of interesting
results about how this can improve the
dependence of these algorithms on the
horizon that's
h the number of steps that you take
um so that's one sort of interesting use
of of ucb
um another interesting use of ucb and
this is area in which uh devervat shaw
and his collaborators have been involved
is in the study of what's known as monte
carlo tree search
mcts for short it's a very clever idea
and it's a key ingredient of some of the
modern successes of reinforcement
learning particular
the alphago system for um for playing go
uses this technique heavily
and it's essentially a way of trying to
estimate
value functions from samples by rolling
out a decision tree that
tracks the states and actions that you
make in a in a sequence
forming a tree as we see here
the bandit part comes in because
the this is an adaptive data collection
procedure
so you can sort of think that at every
node you have a multi-arm bandit problem
to solve
at each one of these nodes there's a set
of actions that i can take
and in exploring this tree to find the
optimal path i essentially need to solve
a highly coupled sequence of multi-arm
bandit problems
so denver rotten and his colleagues have
done some some theory on this some nice
theory trying to characterize exactly
when this works
and how it works a key difference is you
actually have to use polynomial
confidence
bounds instead of typical logarithmic
ones here
okay so there's there's many future
directions here i think in the interests
of time i'll i'll skip
but um many interesting things that the
team
plans to explore um through this
institute
so let me move on to our next direction
um our next direction has to do with
getting instant optimal bounds in
reinforcement learning
and here we're motivated by the the
classical fact that
um standard minimax bounds these are
various things that are proved are worst
case in nature
so most of the bounds i've quoted so far
are worst case
for instance saying that the scaling and
the horizon is cubic that's worst case
the fact of the matter is that many
methods
work far better in practice than the
existing theory would suggest
um in fact when i was sort of playing
around with q-learning
um it its worst case dependence on the
horizon is cubic
but if you want to construct a problem
that actually achieves that you have to
work
pretty hard you can't just sort of
construct a generic problem
and get this worst case scaling most
generic problems methods behave much
much better
so what we'd like to do here is we'd
like to obtain a finer grained
characterization of
the sample complexity and also
computational complexity
of rl methods
so let me give you a quick vignette in a
very simple setting so if we just look
at
the problem of estimating the value
function of a policy
in a discounted mdp okay so
in this setup we have a function the
value function v star and it satisfies
bellman's equation it's equal to the
reward
plus the discount factor the expectation
of the value function for future states
s primed conditioned on that state
in the td learning problem we don't we
don't know the distribution
e that's being used to compute
expectations but we get samples
and so we can compute noisy versions of
this bellman fixed point equation
those are called temporal differences
hence the name td learning
and td learning is just a standard
natural stochastic approximation
algorithm it says well
if you had the right value function then
these differences would be
zero mean they're random variables but
in expectation there would be zero mean
so you should just push your policy push
your value function
with small step sizes in that direction
to make that zero
okay so that's a classical algorithm one
of the
most widely used algorithms and it can
be improved with something known as
polyacryl averaging um
so there's lots known about the worst
case behavior of td learning but
what we focused on here is is on a
notion known as
instance optimality um
what does it mean to be instance optimal
well luckily statistics again someone
from berkeley le com
gives us a very precise notion of what
it means for a statistical procedure to
be instance optimal
um lecom theory can be used to
characterize
the um at least asymptotically the
structure of the covariance matrix
that an optimal method should achieve
and so if we look at that for this
policy evaluation problem
it has a very natural form um
in the middle you have the variance of
the bellman update that's the update
the fixed point equation you're trying
to solve and on the left and the right
should be a transpose on one of these
you have
i minus gamma the discount factor times
the transition operator of the markov
chain
um that sort of if you invert
take um the von neumann series of that
inverse you're sort of taking powers of
p you're looking at all future
transitions of the markov chain
so you can ask well does td achieve this
and the answer is like many questions
the answer is both yes and no
if you do td learning with poliak rupert
averaging that's
a pretty standard device and stochastic
approximation
it will achieve this bound
asymptotically for very large sample
sizes
but in modern practice we look at finite
sample sizes and
we'd like to know will the method
actually be optimal for a finite sample
size
um and this method's actually
sub-optimal it's asymptotically optimal
but you can demonstrate for fixed t
there are algorithms that strictly
dominate this algorithm
and in our work we actually proposed one
such algorithm that is strictly better
than
than td learning
so some results from this paper but in
the interest of time let me just move
forward
so just to wrap up let me talk about a
last direction
this one i think is is very topical and
it's also
nicely connected with the causal
inference thrust
and this has to do with doing reform
reinforcement learning in
offline settings so in an offline
setting
um you've collected data using one
policy let's call it the behavior policy
that's been stored somewhere and you'd
like to
use that data set to learn other things
possibly about other policies
now why would you like to do this well
for instance imagine in again
self-driving cars
if you have a new policy and you don't
know whether it's safe or not or stable
or not
you can't necessarily just roll it out
in the real world to collect on policy
data
it's much better if you can have off
policy data collected from
a known and safe policy and you can
evaluate the performance of a new policy
using the offline data
so this is a very active area both in
bandit world and in reinforcement
learning and there's many open questions
here
as i said there are lots of connections
with causal inference things like
instrumental variables
um inverse propensity scores doubly
robust
robust methods synthetic controls um
these are all sort of
standard ideas from causal inference
that either have
had impact already on offline rl or
people are continuing to explore them
um i think the instance optimality
questions here for these offline
problems are wide open
and very interesting to study
and another question that susan
highlights is
often you want to select actions that
are suitable for some kind of secondary
data analysis
so for instance she works a lot on
clinical trials
and so there you actually want to spend
it's very expensive to collect data and
you want to do a lot of
post collection analysis of it so
they're interesting problems actually
interactions between how you collect the
data that's going to become offline
and what can be done with it after it's
collected
so i'll wrap up there
but thanks very much for your time
thanks martin so um
if there are any quick questions
um now's your chance
otherwise um let's say a big thank you
to
to martin and to all of the speakers
today um you know it was a great
collection of talks
um uh and you know a reminder of the
the fodzy postdoc positions uh that
advertisement
you can you can find the details on the
fodzy.us
website um so you know
trying to get the word out there um
thanks a lot all for attending
that was um uh very very fun event
thank you thanks for organizing peter
and piotr